[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Barbara halweg guten Abend und
willkommen zum Nachrichtenüberblick an
diesem Freitag Norbert König ist auch
dabei für den Sport ja guten Abend und
das sind die Themen von heute
durchwachsenes Zeugnis die
corona-maßnahmen waren laut Expertenrat
nur teilweise wirksam
gaspreisexplosion die Bundesregierung
will die Mehrkosten offenbar auf alle
Kunden umlegen
und koloniale Raubkunst nach 125 Jahren
sollen die sogenannten benin-bransen
wieder zurückgegeben werden
[Musik]
seit fast zweieinhalb Jahren Ringen wir
mit Corona gerade gehen die Inzidenzen
wieder steil nach oben und mit Blick auf
Herbst Winter wäre es extrem wichtig zu
wissen welche der bisherigen Maßnahmen
gewirkt haben
Stichwort Lockdown maskenpflicht 2G oder
3g-regelungen heute präsentierte der
Sachverständigenrat seinen
Abschlussbericht Tenor bei einigen
Maßnahmen ist unklar was sie gebracht
haben andere wirken nur wenn die
Menschen auch mitziehen konkrete
Handlungsanweisungen für die Politik gab
es nicht Andrea Maurer hat Details
immer wieder wurde die Veröffentlichung
verschoben nun hält der
Gesundheitsminister den Sachverständigen
Bericht in den Händen es ist eine Art
Zeugnisübergabe und doch ist Bewertung
nicht abschließend möglich auch nach
zwei Jahren Pandemie fehlen Daten
die Kritik also an der also mangelnden
Verfügbarkeit von Daten ist korrekt aber
ich blicke nach vorne und nicht nach
hinten mir liegt es auch fern hier also
Vorgängerinnen und Vorgänger zu
kritisieren 165 Seiten umfasst der
Bericht die Wirksamkeit vieler Maßnahmen
aber kann nicht eindeutig beurteilt
werden eine Einordnung versucht das
Gremium trotzdem etwa beim Thema
Lockdown
wenn erst wenige Menschen infiziert sind
hat es einen besonderen Effekt aber
lockdowns wirken eben auch nur wenn der
Mensch mitmacht je länger ein Lockdown
dauert und je weniger Menschen bereit
sind die Maßnahmen mitzutragen das haben
einige Studien gezeigt desto geringer
ist der Effekt und umso mehr schwerer
werden eben auch die unerwünschten
Wirkung die Wirkung von
Schulschließungen strittig den Effekt
von 2G und drei geregeln sehen die
Experten mit Omicron geschwächt Masken
wirksam aber nur wenn sie richtig
getragen werden der Bericht liegt nun
bei den politischen Entscheidern die FDP
hat ihn zur Voraussetzung gemacht für
ampelverhandlungen über weitere
Maßnahmen wir können nach dem was wir
heute wissen sicher sagen dass Eingriffe
wie lockdowns wie Schulschließungen und
Ausgangssperren nicht mehr
verhältnismäßig sind mit diesen
Instrumenten wollen wir nicht mehr
arbeiten in den Reihen der Grünen
dagegen heißt es heute Aussagekraft des
Berichts sei begrenzt die Ampel wird
wohl noch im Juli einen Vorschlag machen
für das Vorgehen in diesem corona-
heiztmuster mit rechnen dass das jetzt
schnell sehr viel teurer wird die
Bundesregierung plant die gestiegenen
Gaspreise auf alle Schultern zu
verteilen ein entsprechender
Gesetzentwurf liegt dem ZDF und der
Nachrichtenagentur Reuters vor damit
sollen Gasversorger gestützt werden die
durch den Wegfall von russischen Gas zu
hohen preisenersatz besorgen müssen aus
Berlin Elisabeth Schmidt
es kommt immer weniger Gas aus Russland
heißt die deutschen Energieversorger
müssen in anderen Ländern immer teurer
Gas Einkaufen die Mehrkosten könnten
bald alle Gaskunden gleichermaßen tragen
im Gesetzentwurf der Ampelkoalition zwei
entscheidende Punkte die Bundesregierung
darf hierbei ohne Zustimmung des
Bundesrats tätig werden und
Energieversorger können über eine Umlage
finanziell entlastet werden also wenn es
so eine allgemeine Umlage gäbe dann
würde das zwar für einige Verbraucher
die absoluten Preisspitzen nehmen und
reduzieren aber in der Summe würde das
für alle Endverbraucher trotzdem gleich
sein das heißt die Energieanbieter
würden die Großhandelspreise vollständig
an die Endverbraucher also auch an die
privaten Haushalte durchreichen immer
mehr Energieversorger befürchten
allerdings in finanz Seele Schieflage zu
geraten und begrüßen deshalb die Pläne
der Bundesregierung das ist ein
richtiger Schritt wir wissen ja seit
letzter Woche dass immer weniger Gas aus
Russland kommt unsere gasimporteure
müssen diese fehlenden Mengen teuer am
Spotmarkt beschaffen und das führt
natürlich zu erheblichen Belastungen
also wir haben tatsächlich Angst davor
dass wir eine Finanzkrise im Gashandel
sehen werden die Wirtschaftsminister der
Länder schwören die gesamte Gesellschaft
bei ihrem Treffen heute schon mal auf
Verzicht ein jede Kilowattstunde zählt
deswegen sind auch Einsparmaßnahmen
sowohl in der Wirtschaft aber auch bei
Bürgerinnen und Bürgern unser Appell aus
dieser
wirtschaftsministerkonferenz
Energiesparen allein dürfte dennoch
nicht ausreichen die Gasrechnung wird
wohl bald massiv steigen
Theo Koll in Berlin warum muss das mit
dem neuen Gesetz jetzt so schnell gehen
ich bin gleich aus zwei Gründen erstens
sieht man ja schon jetzt das mit uniper
der erste große Energiekonzern Alarm
schlägt und starte hier Hilfe erbittet
und zweitens wird in zehn Tagen die
hauptpipeline Nord Stream 1 für
Wartungsarbeiten abgeschaltet und es
wird hier befürchtet das Utensil auch
abgeschaltet lässt das würde dann die
Gaspreise noch mal massiv in die Höhe
treiben mit erwartbaren Problemen für
die Versorger die teures Gas kaufen ist
aber billiger abgeben müssen damit die
Versorger dann nicht zusammenbrechen
gibt es bisher den § 24 wenn der
aktiviert wird dann können die Versorger
auch in bestehenden Verträgen sofort
neue Preise aufrufen mit der Gefahr
willkürlicher Unterschiede alternativ
ist jetzt ein umlagemechanismus in
Planung das heißt die Mehrkosten würden
durch alle Verbraucher geteilt und als
Umlage draufgeschlagen das ganze ist
jetzt unter Hochdruck in der
Ressortabstimmung und soll möglichst
schon kommende Woche in den Bundestag
politische Sommerferien das war früher
Dankeschön nach Berlin Theo Koll
seit Corona hat sich der Staat in drei
Haushaltsjahren extrem verschuldet damit
soll jetzt Schluss sein zum Vergleich im
laufenden Jahr liegen die neuen Schulden
noch bei
138,9 Milliarden Euro dagegen sieht der
Haushaltsentwurf für 2023 nur 17,2
Milliarden vor sollte das klappen würde
erstmals seit 2019 die Schuldenbremse
wieder eingehalten aber nicht nur die
Opposition sieht den Plan des
Finanzministers skeptisch Daniel pontzen
moderner als frühere ist der Entwurf
zweifellos die gut 1500 Seiten liegen
digital vor sind dadurch auch leichter
zu durchsuchen so findet sich früh das
Wort Einhaltung bezogen auf die
Schuldenregel im Grundgesetz trotz der
Konsolidierung die gelungen ist schaffen
wir Voraussetzungen für zusätzliche
Entlastungen im Jahr 2023 wir haben eine
globale
mindereinnahme von 9,1 Milliarden Euro
vorgesehen
Lindner greift dabei bereits auf die
sogenannte flüchtlingsrücklage zurück
von den dort angesparten bislang
unangetasteten 48 Milliarden Euro plant
er gut 40 ein trotzdem sei der Plan
wackelig kritisiert die Union dieser
Haushalt ist wie ein Kartenhaus die
wirtschaftlichen Daten die zugrunde
gelegt werden sind von April und Mai die
Steuerschätzung und die wirtschaftlichen
Erwartungen wir müssen jetzt schon davon
ausgehen dass die Dinge nicht so
eintreten wie die Daten sind auf denen
der Haushalt beruht Lindners Spielraum
ist auch dadurch eingeschränkt dass
allein der Schuldendienst wegen der
nunwidersteigenden Zinsen 30 Milliarden
Euro kostet dieses Jahr waren es vier
dennoch sei sparen jetzt in Krisenzeiten
der falsche Weg sagt die Linke der
Haushaltsentwurf steuert überhaupt nicht
gegen sondern ganz im Gegenteil dieser
Haushaltsentwurf ist ein zusätzlicher
Brandbeschleuniger und ich kann alle
Kolleginnen und Kollegen im Parlament
eine ausfordern hier gravierende
Änderungen bei Beratung vorzunehmen wenn
sich die Risiken verschärfen und die
Krisen sich verschärfen dann werden wir
auch neu bewerten müssen und dann aktiv
handeln wir werden uns nicht in die
Krisen hineinsparen sondern das
notwendige finanzieren und dann kann
natürlich auch die notfallregel der
Schuldenbremse kein Tabu sein das Thema
dürfte also auch koalitionsintern
spannend bleiben bevor die
Verabschiedung des Haushalts für Ende
November geplant ist
sollte der Staat noch mehr tun um die
steigenden Preise auszugleichen im ZDF
Politbarometer sind die meisten
Befragten dafür 61 Prozent finden die
Bundesregierung entlastet die Bürger zu
wenig gut ein Viertel hält es für gerade
richtig für sechs Prozent macht die
Regierung zu viel bei der Frage nach
Militärhilfe für die Ukraine fordern 44
Prozent der Westens solle stärker
unterstützen für 32% soll es genauso
bleiben weniger militärische Hilfe
wollen 18 Prozent das ganze
Politbarometer im heute journal ab 22
Uhr und in unserer App
aus der Ukraine selbst heute wieder
erschütternde Nachrichten der Osten
steht weiter unter Beschuss die Stadt
Lissy Chance so heftig dass eine
Evakuierung der Menschen dort unmöglich
sei sagte zuständige Gouverneur und auch
im Süden gab es russische
Raketenangriffe dabei starben nach
ukrainischen Angaben mindestens 20
Menschen auch Kinder glückwal-
kurz vor 1 Uhr nachts schlugen die
Raketen in dem mehrstöckigen Wohnhaus
südlich der Hafenstadt Odessa ein unter
den Trümmern suchten
Rettungsmannschaften stundenlang nach
Überlebenden geschockte Anwohner
versuchten zu helfen
alle haben mit angefasst es waren viele
Opfer ich weiß nicht wie viele aber
viele
das war der dritte schwere Angriff auf
zivile Gebäude in einer Woche nach
Raketen auf einen Wohnblock in Kiew und
einem Einkaufszentrum in krementschuk im
ukrainischen Parlament gedachten die
Abgeordneten mit einer Schweigeminute
der Opfer später wurde unter feierlichem
Applaus die EU-Flagge aufgestellt als
Bekenntnis zu Europa die Ukraine so
Präsident selenski sei fest entschlossen
die vollständige Mitgliedschaft in der
EU zu erreichen zum zerstörten Wohnhaus
hieß es unterdessen in Moskau erneut die
russische armee-reife keine zivilen
Ziele an die Raketen sind nach
ukrainischer Darstellung ein russischer
Racheakt für die Einnahme der
strategisch wichtigen Schlangeninsel vor
der Küste gestern ein Symbol des
ukrainischen Widerstands Schritt für
Schritt zu der Präsident werden wir die
Besatzer zurückdrängen im Wasser im
Luftraum an Land
im Gebiet luhansk 900 Kilometer östlich
von Odessa steht die Stadt Lissy Chance
weiter unter Dauerbeschuss der
russischen Angreifer es gibt keinen
Strom und kein Wasser mehr als 10.000
Bewohner harren dort aus sie hoffen auf
eine sichere Evakuierung
nach Hongkong zu einem wichtigen
Jahrestag vor genau einem
Vierteljahrhundert Grab Großbritannien
die Kronkolonie an China zurück die
Vereinbarung damals Hongkong bleibt noch
50 Jahre frei und unabhängig doch Peking
griff immer härter durch schlug die
Demokratiebewegung 2019
niederschränkte die meinungs- und
Versammlungsfreiheit massiv ein über die
Situation in Hongkong heute berichtet
Miriam Steimer
die chinesische Flagge weht immer ein
kleines Stück höher Präsidentin fing ist
angereist um Hongkongs Rückkehr zu
feiern und um den neuen Regierungschef
John Lee zu vereinigen der ehemalige
Sicherheitschef ist der kommunistischen
Führung in Peking besonders treu manche
erkennen ihre Stadt heute nicht wieder
in dem Hongkong das ich kenne gibt es am
1 Juli Demos heute darf hier niemand für
Freiheit kämpfen von denen die früher
hier waren sind inzwischen viele im
Gefängnis oder haben das Land verlassen
nachdem wir den Sturm überstanden haben
spüren wir schmerzlich das Hongkong es
sich nicht leisten kann chaotisch zu
sein
zumute diesen Koffer hat sie an ihrem
letzten Arbeitstag gepackt sie war
Journalistin bei der
regierungskritischen Apple daily die
gibt es nicht mehr Pressefreiheit auch
nicht ich überlege welche Art
Nachrichten ich machen will und hier
noch machen kann
sie ist vorsichtig denn seitdem 2020
erlassenen Sicherheitsgesetz kann alles
Folgen haben was im weitesten Sinne
gegen china ist ein Land zwei Systeme
das war das Versprechen offiziell hält
hier daran fest politisch hat klar China
das sagen
es scheint als wäre es gerade friedlich
aber ich denke das überdeckt nur die
Machtlosigkeit der Menschen
phoe zweifelt ob es als Journalistin für
Sie in Hongkong noch eine Zukunft gibt
die Türkei sperrt seit gestern Abend die
Internetseiten der Deutschen Welle
Begründung der Sender habe nicht die
erforderliche Zulassung kritiker
befürchten ein Jahr vor den Wahlen eine
weitere Aushöhlung der Pressefreiheit in
der Türkei
Kunst gehört zur bevorzugten Beute von
Eroberern die Museen der westlichen Welt
sind voll davon Beispiel die sogenannten
Benin brancen sie beweisen wie hoch
entwickelt Kunst und Technik in
Westafrika waren die ältesten stammen
aus dem 16 Jahrhundert und sie sind
geklaut britische Truppen zerstörten
1897 den Königspalast und nahm auch alle
brancen mit deutsche Museen kauften sie
gern jetzt sollen sie zurückgegeben
werden an Nigeria den nachfolgestab des
Königreichs Benin Martin Niessen aus
Bronze gearbeitete Köpfe von Königin
Skulpturen von Tieren
Reliefs mit der Darstellung von Kriegern
rund 1.100 Kunstobjekte aus dem
historischen Königreich Benin im
heutigen Nigeria befinden sich in
deutschen Museen wie hier in Hamburg
koloniale Raubkunst für deren Rückgabe
heute in Berlin eine entsprechende
Absichtserklärung unterzeichnet wurde
mit diesem Schritt übernimmt Deutschland
die Führung dabei die Fehler der
Vergangenheit zu korrigieren
Deutschland stelle sich damit auch
seiner eigenen Kolonialgeschichte das
ist keine Geste sondern das ist ein
Stück Gerechtigkeit denn diese Benin
Bronzen wurden unrechtmäßig genommen und
vor allen Dingen wurden sie viel zu
lange behalten
1897 hatten britische Truppen tausende
brancen aus dem geplünderten
Königspalast nach Europa geschafft seit
den 1970er Jahren bemühte sich Nigeria
um deren Rückführung wir sind uns alle
einig dass das ein notwendiger und
wichtiger Schritt ist auch für eine neue
Kultur der Zusammenarbeit mit mit
unserem Partnerländern im globalen Süden
dass wir eben illegal erworbene
Kulturgüter
im kolonialen des kolonialen Kontaktes
Kontextes zurückerstatten als
symbolischer Akt wurden die ersten
beiden Bronzen den Vertretern Nigerias
überreicht weitere sollen noch in diesem
Jahr folgen viele andere aber als
Leihgaben weiter in deutschen Museen zu
sehen sein
das ZDF ist jeden Tag aufs Neue
gefordert mit gut recherchierten
Nachrichten für glaubwürdigen
Journalismus einzustehen sagt die
rheinland-pfälzische Ministerpräsidentin
Malu Dreyer die heute als Vorsitzende
des ZDF Verwaltungsrats wiedergewählt
wurde der Sender müsse ein attraktives
Programm für alle machen schließlich
zahlten auch alle ihren Beitrag
eine Gewitterfront mit Starkregen und
Sturmböen hat in der Nacht in Teilen
Deutschlands große Schäden verursacht
vor allem in Nordrhein-Westfalen und in
Bayern allein in Duisburg gingen 500
Notrufe ein Bäume kippten um und
beschädigten mehrere Autos in einem
Stadtteil fielen die Telefone aus im
südbayerischen Oberstdorf kam es zu
Erdrutschen Straßen wurden überflutet
und Keller liefen voll
das Wetter in Wimbledon war glaube ich
viel besser in Norbert und es gab einige
Überraschungen bei den Frauen ja zwei
deutsche stehen in der Runde der letzten
16 und das ist schon jetzt ein
großartiger Erfolg für die Wimbledon
Debütantin Jule Niemeyer nach ihrem
Dreisatz Sieg gegen die Ukrainerin Lesia
zu Renko und für die 34-Jährige Tatjana
Maria Angelique Kerber dagegen ist
ausgeschieden ein letzter Gruß ans
Publikum es war nicht Angelique kerbers
Tag die Wimbledon-Siegerin von 2018 weit
von ihrem besten rasentennis entfernt
4:567 gegen die solide Spielende
Belgierin Elis Mertens vom Glück
überwältigt dagegen Tatjana Maria die
Mutter zweier Töchter in der Runde der
besten 16 auch dank ihres Ehemanns und
Trainers rechts im Bild
mein Mann ist großartig er gibt mir
Selbstvertrauen ohne ihn wäre ich nicht
hier
auch die Weltranglisten fünfte Maria
sakari lässt sich von den stark
unterschnittenen Bällen der 34-Jährigen
deutschen regelrecht den Zahn ziehen
nach eineinhalb Stunden ist die
Überraschung des Tages perfekt sechs zu
drei und sieben zu fünf Tatjana Maria
zum ersten Mal in ihrer Geschichte hat
die Tour de France in Skandinavien
begonnen beim Auftaktsieg des Belgiers
Eve Lampert im Zeitfahren ist in
Dänemark wenig davon zu spüren dass es
die dritte Tour in pandemiezeiten ist
in einem nahezu maskenfreien Kopenhagen
beginnt die 109 Auflage der Tour de
France mit einem Einzelzeit fahren nicht
nur beim Sieger der letzten beiden Jahre
rollt die Corona Angst mit auf einen
seiner wichtigsten Helfer Matteo Trentin
muss der Slowenisch schon mal verzichten
der Veranstalter und der Weltverband
haben die kobit Regeln liberalisiert
verpflichten getestet wird nur zu Beginn
der Tour und an den Ruhetagen wenn nach
Ansicht der Mediziner keine
Ansteckungsgefahr besteht dürfen positiv
getestete auf weiterfahren Maximilian
schachmann nach seinem heutigen Rennen
zu den Maßnahmen
unser Trost ist getestet das wissen wir
aber außerhalb ja wenig trinke
spätestens bei einer alpias Berg Etappe
wird das auch seine Grenze erreichen so
bleibt es den Teams vor allem selbst
überlassen wie viel Vorsicht sie für
angemessen erachten
und das Glück muss wohl mitradeln
Dankeschön Norbert nach den Unwettern
wird es wieder ruhiger mehr dazu gleich
im Wetter von östant Herrli im heute
journal um 10 spricht Christian Sievers
mit Gesundheitsminister Lauterbach und
hier begrüßt sie morgen Jana pareigges
schönes Wochenende Ihnen auf Wiedersehen
[Musik]
schönen guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter die Kaltfront Sie
uns diese heftigen Unwetter brachte
verabschiedet sich nun allmählich aus
Deutschland dahinter etabliert sich
vorübergehend ein hoch und Warmluft aus
dem Süden erreicht uns so dass die 30
Grad Marke im Südwesten wieder geknackt
wird in der Nacht also nach Nordosten
noch Regenwolken die abziehen ansonsten
klarte ist häufig auf in Gewässernähe
zum Beispiel Richtung Donau bildet sich
Nebel das bei tiefsten Temperaturen um 6
Grad in der Mitte und 14 Grad Richtung
Nordsee lüften Sie noch mal kräftig
durch teilweise sind die Temperaturen
einstellig morgen am Tagesverlauf häufig
Sonnenschein nach Osten hin und auch im
Süden im Norden einige harmlose Wolken
und keinen Regen in Sicht das bei
höchsten Temperaturen von 30 Grads im
Südwesten Deutschlands häufig Werte über
der 25 Grad Marke am kühlsten noch an
der Nordsee mit 23 Grad die nächsten
Tage am Sonntag ist es komplett trocken
nur ganz in Nordwesten kommt zum Abend
etwas Bewirkung mit Regen auf bis 31
Grad danach wird die 30 Grad Marke nicht
mehr geknackt und im Süden gibt es
Gewitter damit ein schöner Abend